grati ai gestori o tv video speciale che
non ho mai fatto ed i miei scritti i
miei followers scelgono lo slime ma lo
fai se mi seguite su instagram avrete
visto che fate i sondaggi in cui mi
chiedevo quali gradiente isolette che
metta nello slime è come volete che
facciano il claim alla vibrazione subito
vedere i risultati e andiamo a fare un
flyer in base ai vostri gusti
se non mi seguite ancora finite nei
mandati a seguirmi pezzo migliore
aggiunge 10.000 l'ice farò un altro di
questi video in cui gli iscritti
scelgono blues live che andrò a fare io
non me tornare di vedere come ck tutta
la nostra l'altro non andrò a fare solo
un in flight non mandro fanno in tre
e poi mettere il cristo ma cosa
succederà come sempre se volete vedere
altri video slam lasciato un bel live
che se volete entrare a far parte della
storia è un alibi basta iscrivermi da
ben vestiti che cliccando nella
campanella e ora siete pronti iniziamo
subito allora il primo sondaggio era
volete lo slide con la colla trasparente
con la colla bianca e per il 59 per
cento quindi strano molini ha vinto con
la trasparenza e quindi iniziamo subito
il ministro primo ingrediente allora
andrò a fare tre piccoli slime e poi
vedrete 4 potrò fare
non so se avete notato ma il background
è cambiato ora mi piace molto di più
molto di minuto e allora nelle vicine
dietro fanno un po stile stringenti
anche se sono tutte gialle
se volete vedere il flop di come la mia
ma piazzata e come stiamo allestendo
addobbando tutto perini blog fila sono
playlist alla fine di questo video
allora fanno alzare la cosa fareste
naturali non è infatti oltre fatta dalla
ciclistica la trasparente vediamo subito
il prossimo sondaggio allora per il
primo sly con gli ho chiesto se volesse
rosa o blu e per il 59 per cento abito
rosa quindi abbiamo colorare il primo di
rosa allora treni caf mi raccomando stai
estendano macchiarsi le mani come sempre
ce la farò vengono vestiti condizione di
rito davanti
avvio di settimana più tardi scotte e
prova ad aprirlo lo conosco per da te
amo anche a tutto lo scout ecco perché
sporchissimo ma rovinate di commenti
segni macchie rosse non meno chiaro ecco
fatto eco loro il primo slime ok mentre
il fatto è in realtà sembra rosso
ma non vi preoccupate perché perderemmo
ad aggiungere altri ingredienti
ma quando sono andato via perché
arrivate lo slam moviola o arancione e
per il 76 per cento avete portato
comunque fateci sapere se vi piace il
mio nuovo sfondo davvero quello che non
è finito devo accorati un sacco di cose
e se sta presentando nei vostri commenti
e suggerimenti di cosa volete che mette
dietro mi è piaciuto tantissimo
suggerimento in cui avete fatto
dimettere il simbolo della storia e
sterili dietro età questo cercano
appunto qualche sito per stampare il
bomber rubini le qualcosa tema conoscere
qualche sito che lo fa bitume loculi nei
commenti via chiese sempre meditate
giallo o rosso e per il 52 per cento
avete scelto giallo quindi il terzo slam
sarà giallo ok la mette un bel giallo
bene
verrà di più bello è questo il giallo
con il dito sul colore preferito tra
questi 3 ingrediente giochetto preferite
i glitter o le palline e voi avete
scelto i glitter perché 59 per cento
quindi andiamo a mettere il tech trade
lime e non mi ha chiesto di che colore
vuole parte id l'inter perché serve il
solito secondo il sito era un po
confusionario ma volete il leader dello
stesso colore dell'islam gialloviola
vado a mettere e glitter viola in quello
giallo questi bellissimi glitter gialli
allora che ne sono lasciasse cambia
inquadratura ravvicinata così potete
vedere meglio il drive
ditemi quale vi piace di più fiora
questo viola per capelli tutti peter
oppure questo dorato questo bellissimo o
quello che si parla non ho visto che
hanno messo tantissimi twitter quindi
vado a palla aggiungerne altri
andiamo ora a mischiarli
bene cosa che sembra troppo ma per
cambiare un pochino comunque mattina al
prossimo sondaggio allora presto un
sondaggio vi ha chiesto perché una barca
o amido di mais 85 per cento vetusti ma
da barba
ora non so come sempre era la schiuma da
barba nel grande slam nella colla
trasparente perché non ho mai provato a
mettere le stime che parlano il conto
spenti almeno un pezzo comunque presente
da barba che è meglio della schiuma da
barba perché non effettua una sorta
opposto
quindi vediamo un po come diventa per
scrivere anche un po di gel da barba che
vada mischiati vediamo cosa succede
[Musica]
e ora passiamo al prossimo ingrediente
vi ho chiesto sempre private le fiches
bulbi all e slash leeds e per il 65 per
cento al diretto fishbone bit che
sarebbero queste perché ci sono per il
football slime io ho questo è un po più
piccoline che sono perfette per
sospendere la mente
benissimo allora ora vado prima ad
attivamente 3 e quindi letto l'ultimo
fondo già che sarà la trasformazione
finale quindi andiamo subito ad
attivarmi uso la soluzione per lenti e
un pochino di bicarbonato
[Musica]
è arrivato vedere applicato anche
sentire i suoni che farlo e mettete
porremo il suo preferito ma non è finita
perché poi ci sarà una trasformazione
finale allora questo è quello viola
questo è quello rosa alla fine è
diventato rotta vedete e questo è quello
che mi è uscito un po più grande e
bellissimo e supersport e ora e fondando
finale era se con le volte che facessimo
sulla il remo o galaxy e per il 54 per
cento ha vinto galante finché è un po
più difficile
allora vi faccio vedere come proverò a
trasformare questi fly michelin galaxy è
un po un esperimento che posso fare
spero che esca bene allora prendono
sotto la volta allora perdendo tecnica
inventata da me che voglio provare da un
po di tempo quindi sono super contento
di trovarla con voi qua allora in questa
ciotola vuota
inizio metto un pochino di glitter lungo
un pochino di glitter argentati sporcato
le mani tipo un pochino di clip bianchi
se voi avete solo un colore potete anche
utilizzare solo quelli bianchi
organizzati allora lasciate lì così non
mischia temi dopodichè pregio dei pezzi
di flash viola ok presenza di estranei
di viola è un linguaggio e prendo un
pezzo di slam e rosa e appoggio fa a
fianco un pezzo di strane giallo poi in
un'altra pezza di fano violato alternate
i colori poi se avete anche altri colori
cose tutti libere anche altri colori
io ho ascoltato questi colori perché
sono quelli che avete scelto voi
altrimenti per uno slang alla questi
magari a criscito colori diversi e
bellissimo per effetto di colori
comunque ora ma sembra assolutamente un
galaxy fit line non domande può
semplicemente chiuderlo e aspettare
magari stecchi paio di giorni e poi
pendino e appunto i colori non sono
proprio quelli del galaxy presso quelli
del gas risultare muoversi celeste blu
viola però insomma vediamo un po come
diventa con tutti i gruppi rini struzzo
per
come diventerà allora ragazza ha deciso
di aggiungere un po di glitter sini
anche sopra e in moto ora vado a
chiuderlo e non ho idea di come
diventerà allora ecco com'è la
situazione adesso sopra non ci scusate
dimenticato di cedere lavezzi qui che
arriviamo un po come diventa tra 3 2 1
allora è passato un giorno e noi andiamo
ad aprirli vediamo come sono diventati
allora se state chiedendo perché sono
due in pratica poi la sera ho visto che
lo slime stava strabordando era troppo
quindi deciso di togliere un pezzo m se
non penso in un altro contenitore in più
ho aggiunto sopra dei brillantini e
glitter in iper quello potrete il tocco
un po diverso allora iniziamo con questo
e poi vediamo come è diventato questo
che fino allora si sono create un sacco
di bolle sopra e poi tutti i brillantini
ovviamente è un po effetto galaxy adesso
effettivamente perché messo i prodotti
di blu e viola mi dispiace anche tirarlo
fuori adesso vediamo sotto
guardate il mix di colori ora non so se
capovolgerlo allora vediamo qua intoppi
innanzitutto
sentite che per moglie per polline
e bellissimo questo effetto è sfumato
con tutti i colori
ora voglio provare a capovolgerlo
guardate si è vantato tipo metallizzato
il colore
wow poi avendo usato la colla
trasparente i brillantini si vedono
tutti anche se non è diventato
trasparente e penso per il gel proviamo
il capovolgerlo vediamo chi staccherà
ragazzi guardate quanti colori rimasto
un pochino pizzico zoe
guardate i colori che belli questi sono
tutti i clip è rimasto tipo con i colori
metallizzati
[Musica]
guardate come brilla è diventato rosa
metallizzato contenti presenzini ora
vediamo il prossimo che sarebbe un pezzo
dell'altro che ho staccato e ha messo
sopra degli altri brillanti lingua rate
contro brin che perdiamo subito
diventato stadi sembra che il colore un
po diverso va più sul giallo ma che bei
colori anche qua sono create le
bollicine
ma guardate come è diventato
questo è diventato un pochino più
trasparente vediamo come diventa una
volta un'occhiata
guardate quanti flitter conti colori
ma fatemi sapere quello che è piaciuto
di più tra questo viola e questo giallo
e se volete che faccia un altro video in
cui scegliete poi i clienti dell'hot
line tramite i sondaggi lasciato un bel
l'iphone questo video e se ragione dei
10.000 likes andano fare un altro video
del genere
se volete farlo i sondaggi su youtube la
parola segreta del giorno è slime super
dritte roso se avete visto il video fino
a qua scrivete nei commenti slime super
glitter oso
e ora che la sua quattro case linee su
cui potete cliccare prevedere il
prossimo video
un bacione e alla prossima